[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et avec nous fatiguent malienne yann
bonsoir vous êtes conseillère
départementale dont le content de
mulhouse 2 avec votre binôme à philippe
trimaille et pour commencer on part de
suite à la découverte de votre canton
c'est là que se trouve le musée de
l'automobile mais ce n'est pas là que
vous emmène adrien halabi au programme
l'espace solidarité de la doller
management sportif du quartier de bondy
villers et la visite de deux entreprises
au coeur de la ville
bienvenue dans le canton de mulhouse 2
c'est ici que se sont installés les
premières cités ouvrières à la grande
époque de l'industrie textile si
aujourd'hui le textile ne fait plus
vivre la cité le canton reste
profondément populaire dans son
peuplement
rue de pfastatt cette grande tour vitrée
accueil l'espace solidarité de la doller
ici les habitants peuvent trouver
l'ensemble des services départementaux
travaillant dans le domaine de
solidarité ici sont concentrées
l'ensemble des services delà de la
solidarité à savoir la gestion du rsa et
de l'insertion mais également toute la
gestion de l'autonomie que ce soit à
destination des personnes handicapées ou
des personnes âgées mais également le
pôle gérontologique à proprement parler
est également la pmi donc la santé la
petite enfance
ayant connu une urbanisation important
dans les années 50-60 le quartier de
bourtzwiller a longtemps été un
concentré des difficultés issues des
grands ensembles depuis dix ans la
municipalité de mulhouse a lancé
différents plans de rénovation urbaine
le département est intervenu en appui
comme ici pour la création de la plaine
sportive de la doller ce bout de
quartier est en pleine requalifier qu'à
sion avec la mise en place de tout un
panel de d'infrastructures sportives le
terrain de football synthétique et vous
avez derrière moi le nouveau gymnase
d'une capacité de 1000 spectateurs le
département est vraiment aux côtés de la
ville de mulhouse et on voit que le
département est un acteur de
l'aménagement du territoire sans lequel
de nombreux projets ne pourraient pas se
faire
implantée à mulhouse depuis 1919
l'entreprise manurhin est un des
fleurons de l'industrie alsacienne ses
200 salariés fabrique des machines
outils pour la production de munitions
de petit calibre un domaine où la pme
s'est imposé comme le leader mondial et
si aujourd'hui le carnet de commandes
est plein l'entreprise a connu des
périodes difficiles son intervention de
l'état et d'investisseurs privés ce
savoir-faire quasi centenaire aurait pu
être perdu l'entreprise a aussi pu
compter sur le soutien des collectivités
une agence de développement économique a
été au côté de la société manurhin
lorsqu'elle en a eu besoin par exemple
pour de la recherche de sous traitants
de la recherche de financements ou des
deux publics ou encore dans le cadre
d'un projet immobilier bien entendu le
chef de file du de l'économie c'est la
grande région mais aux côtés de la
grande région les départements
souhaitent pouvoir être les garants du
maintien du modèle alsacien tel qu'il
existe aujourd'hui
si vous avez consommé des produits
alimentaires fabriqués en alsace il est
pourquoi mme qu'ils aient un moment
transiter sur un convoyeur construit par
natel raison du succès de la petite
entreprise mulhousienne savoir-faire et
innovation dernière en date la
réalisation d'un convoyeur spécial
installé dans le nouveau café ouvert par
la star du design philippe starck une
première mondiale nous nous trouvons
devant l'entreprise n'at-elle qui est
une entreprise de production
industrielle au sein même du quartier
delà de la colère qui en étant implanté
dans le quartier assure une activité
précieuses et de l'emploi également ce
qui est important c'est que toutes les
entreprises quelle que soit leur taille
puis se trouvaient les interlocuteurs
dont ils ont besoin pour pouvoir assurer
leur développement c'est pourquoi
l'agencé de développement économique
cherchent à inciter à la coordination de
l'ensemble des acteurs du développement
économique sur notre territoire de sorte
que les entrepreneurs puissent
rapidement et efficacement trouver
l'interlocuteur dont ils ont besoin
preuve de son succès n'at-elle embauches
l'entreprise cherche actuellement un
mécanicien monteur
fatima liane fonctionnaires c'est un
quartier qui a la réputation d'être
plutôt difficile d'importantes
opérations aux innovations viennent sur
ton cours qu'on l'a vu feu de quoi
s'agit-il oui donc tout d'abord le
quartier c'est un quartier pour juste un
peu vous présentez vauvillers c'est un
quartier donc qui a été rattaché à 2012
en 1947 quatorze mille habitants c'est
le oui c'est vrai et effectivement c'est
un quartier dont qui a été sujet tout
d'abord de la première programme
programmation de la position de la ville
donc et de la rénovation urbaine dont il
a bénéficié d'énormément de dette parce
qu'on appelle la solidarité nationale
effectivement que comme il vient de dire
donc mon collègue philippe trimaille
de nombreuses projets ont été menés dans
cette opération donc qui ont favorisé le
cadre de vie des habitants qui ont
favorisé dans que l'améliorer
l'amélioration des logements
on peut citer donc la destruction des
420 donc des foyers fin 80 et la
reconstruction de logements de grande
qualité
respectueuse dans l'environnement
l'économie d'énergie donc qui permet aux
gens quand même d'avoir donc des
factures
d'électricité et de chauffage
moins importante que dans les habitats
dont d'autres habitants donc il ya aussi
logiest son programme de rénovation
urbaine donc qui a aussi donc améliorer
le cadre de vie des habitants de la rue
de toulon il ya des parcs de jeux qui se
sont construits au profit des mamans et
des enfants et qui ont amélioré aussi la
relation intergénérationnelle parce que
quand il n'y avait pas ces parcs de jeux
les enfants jouer sur les routes et
c'était pas évident pour les personnes
âgées parce que ça faisait des bruits
etc donc tout ça a fait cette rénovation
urbain de cette solidarité nationale et
bien sûr en partenariat que le
département est avec la ville de
mulhouse ont fait que le quartier c'est
un quartier très agréable très apaisé
bien deux contre un ce n'est plus le
quartier que que le quartier chaud etc
c'est plus tout à fait ça d'ailleurs
par exemple un chiffre quand on avait
commencé la rénovation urbaine donc les
personnes concernées c'était presque
huy 1300 habitants aujourd'hui avec les
la nouvelle géographie de la politique
de la ville il ya uniquement
3200 personnes qui sont concernées et
donc le travail a eu un résultat epide
le nombre d'habitants qui sont concernés
par la police de la ville ne sont plus
les mêmes qu'un est justement dans le
cadre de ces rénovations sur l'habitat
les infrastructures mais aussi la boirie
comment on met l'humain au coeur de ces
transformations justement c'est ce que
je viens de dire bas donc c'est cette
rénovation urbaine a permis donc la
création de terrains de foot donc au
profit des jeunes de baudelaire a permis
la création de ce gymnase qui va être
inaugurée en 2016 au profit des jeunes
collégiens de boeing leur a permis la
création de logements au profit aussi
donc des habitants gosses muller et pas
uniquement parce qu'il ya maintenant il
ya pas mal de mixité donc comme je l'aï
dit dans le quartier donc les personnes
les habitants concernés cette géographie
maintenant qui est normalement d'y
signer suivant donc l'auteur de pauvreté
et il est vraiment minime donc sur
baudelaire il ya aussi donc là
l'école victor hugo qui sera concerné
par ce projet de la rénovation urbaine
vous voyez bien donc il ya des enfants
les mamans et les jeunes
va dans les sons et les moyens qui sont
concernés tout le monde à bénéficier de
cette rénovation urbaine tant mieux pour
le quartier et c'est un quartier
paisible dernière question au niveau de
news mills reste une ville industrielle
mais c'est aussi à l'économie numérique
qui se développe et qui nécessitent des
emplois très qualifiés il ya des outils
pour amener à les personnes en recherche
d'emploi vers ces postes oui là vous me
donnez l'occasion pour parler de la
politique donc d'insertion au niveau
département c'est une politique très
dynamique dans laquelle le département
consacre presque un budget de 10
millions d'euros dont 800 mille auront
du fonds social européen
cette politique dynamique
se concrétise aussi avec des partenaires
institutionnels et à la direccte pôle
emploi et la région mais pas uniquement
les institutions et aussi dans un
partenariat avec des associations sur le
terrain d'ailleurs sur le canton se
contentent 2011 de il ya douze
structures qui accompagnent
les personnes en difficulté un
accompagnement social un accompagnement
socioprofessionnel et c'est cet
accompagnement qui permet à des jeunes
de l'entente à des jeunes ou des
bénéfices est intéressant
d'apprendre
accéder à un emploi et on propose des
contrats aidés si on propose aussi donc
des des stages on propose des formations
et cela permettra probablement un débit
limité intéressés d'accéder à des
emplois qualifiés